this is DW news Africa a giant leap for
tiny Malawi that's also a big step
forward for Africa the people of the
southern african nation have given their
clear backing to a new president i'll
stick the incumbent and electing the man
at the head of an opposition alliance
but it's been a long hard struggle for
Lazarus chapada to make it to Capitol
Hill in the long way a stolen vote and
the second poll were all hurdles he had
to overcome after a trip to Malawi's
High Court now that that ruling has come
it is milometer has won it is democracy
that as one it is Africa that has won
Africa is amazing Malawi is magnificent
but the electron Alliance that brought
Shakira to power is already looking
fragile Malawi's used what he to his
victory now they say the president is
heartless promises were made to make
sure that young people are
part-and-parcel over they developmental
process as well as the decision-making
at all levels of government but then
what happened in Malawi be a model for
Africa I lost the President himself what
his agenda is and we've asked people
across the continent if democracy can
depose the old men in power where they
are can't happen here
come that one you are dreaming I'm
kidding
the means it's hopeful that in camera
one they will get to that place where
the cars can make rulings based on facts
and not based on who is the ruler it is
officials learned to respect their
constitutions and supreme law in every
African country
[Music]
hello I'm Christine Monroe all that and
more coming up on the program welcome
it's good to have you along
Lazarus Chuck we're comfortably beats
speedometer Rica with nearly 60% of the
verge marking the first time in African
history that an election rerun led to
the defeat of an incumbent but it all
started with a peaceful election in 2019
that went terribly wrong the queues were
long and their hopes were high with the
economy on its knees and unemployment
sky-high
for many in Malawi the may 20 19
elections were finally a chance for
change but it didn't take long for them
to realize that something wasn't right
election observers and the opposition
cried foul saying the poll had been
raped donut alleys had been altered with
simple correction fluid Lazarus Sequeira
and his party challenged the result in
the courts
but Peter Mutara can claim victory and
fought back as president he leaned on
the judges and even tried to force one
judge into retirement for many
especially the youth enough was enough
scenes like these were previously
unheard of in the largely stable and
peaceful Malawi and for the first time
deep fractures were visible in the
country but the Supreme Court stood its
ground against an angry president
Mutharika
and the elections were annulled finally
after months of legal battles and
protests the rerun elections were held
in June 2020
we believe this is our date with destiny
and this is the time for the beginning
of a new Malawi as Malawi and celebrate
a new chapter in their history they also
look back at what has been a very
divisive election process the new
president will have to find ways to
reunite the country so long as I am
president I will insist that no new
Malawi must be built except that which
is built by Malawi and that's us
Shakira was elected on a coalition
platform to keep the alliance together
he will have to show he can boost the
economy and fight rampant corruption his
supporters are expecting dramatic change
and change that happens soon Lazarus
Jawara might yet find that getting
elected could turn out to be the easy
part so who is Malawi's new president
Lazarus Shakira here's a brief portrait
of the pastor turned politician who some
have been describing as Malawi's Martin
Luther King
Lazarus Shakira is not the usual
malawian politician the 65 year old was
born in a village near the capital a
long way with no electricity or running
water he has four children with his wife
Monica in his spare time he liked
reading and listening to music including
country and gospel music he says he
bencher din to politics to answer a call
from God one day God spoke to my heart
and God was not saying I'm pulling you
out of ministry God was saying I am
extending your ministry this former
evangelical pastor studied theology in
Malawi South Africa and the US in 2013
he emerged as the leader of the mCP the
Malawi and Congress party without any
previous political experience he says he
brings a new kind of leadership driven
by the needs of Malawians
fighting corruption together I'm not
gonna protect nobody and we want
everybody to know the charismatic
Lazarus Sequeira is a man of God in a
deeply religious country commander
Malawi defends for
[Music]
and I am now joined by the man himself
president lesser is Shakira welcome to
DW news Africa mr. president many people
were surprised by the developments in
your country were you not really I was
not surprised because these development
had taken a over a long period of time
and when all the events were added up it
was a sure sign that Malawi was up for a
change and so I wasn't really surprised
mr. president you lost the election the
host may and and your contender went on
to be inaugurated that's something that
we covered here on Deutsche endroit
develop today you are president what
what do you attribute your being in
office to well a series of events did
not accept the fact that I had lost and
so I went to the courts together with my
colleague who is now vice president and
we mounted a legal battle through our
witnesses and our lawyers until the
court which was the Constitutional Court
are now that result and so even after
the Supreme Court sustained that
judgment we went on to hold fresh
elections and that's why today I'm
president mr. president what is your
vision for Malawi you've said that you
want the country to be unified how are
you going to convince the 42% of
Malawians who didn't vote for you
actually I went out to seek their trust
in me when I took off of office and said
even if you did not vote for me I want
you to know that the new Malawi that
would be good for all of us and so I I
believe that what we have presented
before the Malawian population in terms
of offering leadership that serves them
and leadership that you now
leadership that creates an environment
in which everyone can prosper leadership
that will deal with corruption and theft
of public funds as we follow the rule of
law I believe that we'll be able to do
that mr. president I'd like for you to
have a listen to a man that we heard
from in the long run I'd like to hear
your response to that all we need is for
him to fall through three quarters of
his promises I'm sure he cannot meet all
his promises if he does that we will
agree that this is the promise president
that we've always wanted to have but if
he just makes promises like the reduced
price for fertilizer and doesn't do that
then we will go back to the streets
here's a Malawi insane deliver all will
boot you out how patient do your
supporters have to be I mean after all
they have waited a long time for change
that's correct and we have promised that
we will reduce the price of fertilizer
and this planting season they will see
that promise come to pass and I believe
that we are well able to fulfill our
promises because I am one that beliefs
not just in talking and walking the talk
and I believe that they will be able to
see them mr. president I just want to
highlight the fact that you have
appointed the lawyers who mounted the
legal challenge against the first
election as justice minister and as
Attorney General isn't that just jobs
for the president's inner circle no it's
not you must understand that these are
professional men and this country needs
the advice professionally professionally
trained people that are able to know
that a president will be held
accountable as he has promised to really
stick to the Constitution and to the
rule of law it has nothing to do with
what they did
it had everything to do with what they
are because there are people of
integrity and people who are able to
mount service to the mullerian
population with integrity and ours
Malawi is citizens they took to the
streets again and again and you came to
the power with the support of of a nine
party alliance my question to you here
is just how important is a healthy civil
society it is extremely healthy because
people must be given the right to demand
their rights and we must create an
environment in which people are free to
do the same and so I have no qualms
about letting civil society grow in its
influence because that is a surface to
Malawians that we all need to have you
have come into office with with
overwhelming support from Malawians but
but so have other leaders on the
continent who who've then gone on to
overstay will you be different in other
words will you not become a dictator
becoming a dictator has to do with one's
ego believe in that perhaps nobody else
can do what I only can do and I don't
have that spirit in me but that is only
to be shown at the passage of time I
believe in telling the people that truth
and I believe in walk in that truth I
believe that what we promise we will
keep and that is to say stick with the
constitutional requirements and not seek
to change the same for one's benefit
well mr. president you are going to find
yourself in the company of people who've
been doing just the opposite of what
you're saying you're going to meet these
colleagues at setec meetings at the
African Union what is going to be your
message on the continental stage my
message is what we have given the world
even at this time get institutional
strong enough to do their work
independently and get presidents that
are able to stick to what they promised
and I intend to be one such president
mr. president do want to push you more
on that point because in as much as this
is a victory for those who supported you
in Malawi you all know that there are
many people on the continent young
people as well much like the young
people in Malawi who are still hoping
for change in their countries they're
going to see you going to AU meetings
and they're going to be hoping that
being a refreshing face perhaps you will
bring a refreshing message to the
African Union I want to pose that
question to you again do you think you
also have a burden to speak to your
peers in the president's office for
example presidents of other countries
about ruling for the better of their
countries and living to to the word that
you you profess to going to live by you
know I believe in in that I have been
able to speak truth to power even before
I became president I've been able to
tell the truth even as I have become
president and I intend to be able to
speak truth with love and honestly to my
colleagues whenever I meet them I
believe that African young people this
is the majority of Africans deserve much
better even from a generation of other
folks like us I believe that we must
create an environment in which young
people's rights are respected and they
also are given the chance to demand for
such rights I believe that this is a new
day for Africa and we can set that
example here in malaria speaking about
young people mr. president there are
young people who've lost faith in their
politics and institutions all over the
continent they don't feel taking part in
elections
changes anything because of things like
rigging what words of encouragement do
you have to a young person sitting in a
country who's given up hope who says the
corruption is just going to thrive
forever we're going to have a leader in
power who it doesn't matter what we say
but this person will stay in power what
is your message of encouragement to that
person today
absent to a young person do not
hope hope is the only ingredient of
those who are alive so that they do not
fall into the pursuit piece of
hopelessness and therefore destroying
even the very foundation upon which
something good can come
I believe that young people should have
that hope and see the example that
Malaya as a country has set for all of
the continent and all of the world it is
possible to really get things changed it
is possible to have institutions act
independently it is possible for us to
have systems that will ensure that young
people are protected and are given the
future they desire and that they
participate in the process of changing
that future which they want presidential
era I will say thank you in your mother
tongue Chichewa and I'm told that would
be recall more thank you very much
president Lazarus Shakira of Malawi the
Columbia that's thank you very much
[Music]
you heard president Shakira they're
speaking to me just after his
inauguration we recorded that interview
earlier what we didn't know then was the
final lineup of his cabinet on the face
of it it looks like progress for example
39% of the appointees are women but some
other aspects of Malawi's new government
have had people wondering if it's just
more old-style political patronage our
reporter in Malawi Elson shigera sent
has this update on the concerns of many
Malawi ins in the capital Lilongwe what
a difference
two days make just hours after he was
inaugurated the new president announced
the lineup of his new cabinet but for
many of his supporters it had a tired
old look now 70% of Malawi's population
comprises of young people and to have a
cabinet a leader failing to identify
capable young people to be part of the
cabinet's I think that's a very very
wrong signal
young people in Malawi expect more young
people in Malawi expect that they will
be part and parcel of their
decision-making processes
activists from the youth decide campaign
are already crying foul pointing to the
promises made to them of cabinet
involvement for youth representatives
young people held a lot of
demonstrations so that we could be
considered in the running of the affairs
of the state most of us have made
enemies of our relatives and friends to
ensure that we usher in this government
to end our problems but this is contrary
to our hopes and that's not all
community leaders say that the new
government is dominated by faces from
the Lilongwe region check wheras home
area flying in the face of his place to
strive for national unity what's more
many of them are related to each other
I think previously the government that
was there the ruling party that was
there was appointing people from
from hood and people were accusing it of
being regional istic do you look at this
cabinet it's almost the same and
actually these people are saying this is
West because he is best on families you
have people husband and wife being in
the same family in the same cabinet
despite his seemingly groundbreaking
election the president's political
honeymoon looks like it might be one of
the shortest in history you heard Chaco
era in the interview earlier insisting
that he had made his cabinet appointment
solely on merit that may be raising some
eyebrows now but Chuck where is victory
sent a ripple of enthusiasm through the
continent we've been asking Africans for
their views starting with Zimbabwean
political activist Linda Masseria in
Harari
I don't see that happening in the bubble
anytime soon because in Zimbabwe we've
got a very sophisticated case where
we've got a dog-eat-dog in cannibalism
type of politics politics of patronage
politics of personalities and as long as
we have got the same mentality of having
the politics that have felt to work in
the past 40 years for the ruling party
and the past 20 years for the MDC we are
not going anywhere
we need sincerity in reforms political
reforms coming from both the MDC and
zanu-pf and as long as we have the same
style of self leadership and the same
system operating within MDC and zanu-pf
we are not going anywhere and there's no
way we'll be able to even come next to
having a rerun after elections or a
disputed elections because taking us
back to 2018 elections where the MDC
we're crying that they'd be reached
their first option they were supposed to
take if they were sincere was to ask for
a recount they did not ask for that to
recount because they did not have the
v11 per se and secondly if they were
sincere they should have at first pushed
for a recount before going for a
constitutional challenge so we've got
this dog-eat-dog scenario that we have
there's no political sincerity and at
the end of the day if you're not sincere
and taking the electoral processes in
the channel that we're supposed to take
them when we've got a dispute we are not
doing any justice to the people of what
but we continue the political
grandstanding which are felt to achieve
results
in the past 40 years of the money that
was some Bobby and political activist
Linda Masseria
excuse me the continent has more than
its fair share of old men who cling to
power take my home country and Malawi's
neighbors zimbabwe after independence in
1980 it had decades of rule by one man
Robert Mugabe
he was only deposed in 2017 in a
military backed palace coup which
installed his longtime Ally AMISOM
nagawa as president but he's not Pro
changed for some beaubien snow
prosperity with inflation running at 800
percent the country has had many
disputed elections we asked people in
Harari if they thought what happened in
Malawi could happen in Zimbabwe the
Malone's were able to one to fight is a
united opposition secondly they were
able in the first election before they
ran off to be able to monitor and
observe the electro conduct and thirdly
they were managed to present their
issues before the course that it was so
convincing and I think they are lessons
that these problems in opposition should
be learning from them allowance that
they reserve the rest power in unity
there is a power in dream things in a
meticulous way in terms of monitoring
and observing of their quality of the
elections and thirdly to be able to put
out a position with resonance with the
majority of the people so that they
would elect you and accepting the
platform on which you would be
campaigning on it's still a brilliant
idea but it's still very far from us
because we're even still trying to
manipulate the the peaking of the
judiciary so I mean you look at other
cases even we're on it we don't even
have a jury system in this country so
that means that you have a system that's
that's in a hand of an individual so it
and individuals can be manipulated
either way you know I mean so it's it's
not in the near future I'm not very
hopeful about there happening in
Zimbabwe where as long as
in judiciary in the military do not
support moves even which are are genuine
by the opposition there's no way this
such a move can check places about
unless maybe miracle happens and why one
way or one year when elections are held
the opposition wins then all of a sudden
the systems in leadership allows the
opposition to lead wavered statements
from those in powers and way of saying
even if the news elections they are
still going to use other means to make
sure that Sampath continues to win so I
don't see them giving in they will do
anything for the for them to retain
power further north it is a similar
picture in Uganda a general election is
due there next year but restrictions on
campaigning imposed because of the
coronavirus crisis have raised concerns
that longtime President Yoweri Museveni
could benefit he's already been in power
since 1986 now more than three decades
under one leader that's not left you can
dance with much faith that the Malawian
model could be coming their way anytime
soon listen to what people are saying in
Kampala it can't happen here
it's gone that one you are dreaming I'm
telling you that is the real dream he is
conducting but suddenly the sphere
around he will remain he can't go
you will remain that's wait we are going
in votes you will receive what you're
happy the position can't win
because they are not together unlike
marawis Uganda is a military government
and there is no chance at all for an
opposition coalition because even if the
hundred of them uniting with each other
throughout one candidate the person who
declares the winner is the same the
electro commission appointed by the
President of Uganda and there has never
been a free and fair election in Uganda
and I don't have any hope that it is
going to be free and fair if we have one
operation candy every country has
different the different circumstances
that lead to change I met up in the Arab
world is not what is happening right
here as much as a lot of this content
given this lockdown measures so much
corruption levels I don't think people
have been pushed to the wall that much
to vote on this government in western
Africa Cameroon has been wracked by
ethnic violence separatism a
heavy-handed military human rights
abuses and a dysfunctional government
the incumbent president Bo BIA is
Africa's longest-serving leader in fact
the longest serving of all non boil
heads of state in the world he seized
power in a coup 45 years ago sir what do
people think on the streets of Cameroon
is the Malawian combination of people
power and a pastor turned politician
something they can take hope from yes
what happened in Malawi I'm hopeful that
it will quali happen in Cameroon because
I believe that it's a wing of change
that is about to blow in Africa and
Cameron will not be an exceptional case
so I'm just praying that our
constitutional council leaders who copy
this example and of course they know
that is something that is the right
thing to do and I pray that they will do
it with the next coming of presidential
elections
and I hope that everyone will be happy
with this wing of change in Africa now
with the current system in place in my
country it's almost impossible for
something like this to happen because if
if we have to experience on me like that
so many layers have to be scraped off of
the judicial system and of the
democratic ladder and which that is
where it becomes very very impossible
there are some people wounds give up
their positions for anything it almost
feels like it's it's a dynasty where I
live and somebody fits him into my
position elections have been rigged on a
regular basis so if we can see in
Mallory Dada
the independent cut has been independent
and means it's hopeful that in camera
one they will get to that place where
the cuts can make rulings based on facts
and not based on who is the ruler
oh well it's which party they belong to
because we have faced that kind of
challenge severally so it's a good
example it's something we can really
applaud and hope for our country where
our parts can become independent and
make decisions based on findings and
facts and not based on who pays them I
will fix them so it's giving us hope
that you don't need to be in the ruling
party to be the president of the country
you need to just be someone that has the
right the right vision for the country
and that people can vote you into power
and not because you have the push of the
sitting party or the incumbent party so
it's a good example and I really want to
applaud that and hope that it will be
the case of Cameroon in the nearest
future so where does all this leave us
the voices reveal a place between
despair and hope that's all too familiar
across Africa
finally a last word from Zimbabwe and
political activist Linda Masseria
herself a former opposition candidate in
Harare it is still a problem in Africa
where we have leaders who've got a sense
of over exerted Authority where they do
not have value constitutional remedies
to the crisis that they have you speak
of the electoral crisis so for most
African countries we have to learn to
abide to constitutionalism
as long as we are not abiding to the
Constitution's of our own country we are
going to continue having the same crisis
in all African countries it is high time
that public officials learn to respect
the laws of the land learn to respect
their constitutions and supreme law in
every African country that is the only
way we'll be able to have free and fair
elections that everyone will be happy
with in Africa Zimbabwe and political
activist Linda mozzerella there that is
it for now from DW news Africa you can
catch all our stories on our website and
Facebook page we leave you now with
these images of Malawi's political leap
forward and Shakira's road to the
presidency we'll see you next time
bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you